before you start working on dealing with
judgment one must stop judging if you're
one to judge you're going to be
susceptible to valuing the concept of
judgment attention is the number one
asset what else can I answer for
everybody before I bounce off to this
thing question I was going live daily to
say hi to people who would be on my live
I had a great format but felt like it
was getting old how do I innovate on
live Joe I think it's about changing up
the content this is a big game of it's
kind of like outfits like if you wear
the same clothes every day it's harder
for people they may like that they may
like your outfit but like at some point
it just becomes noise you got to mix it
up and like I thing most people don't um
mix it up does Tik Tok feel like old
YouTube at
all I mean I think I think there's
similarities to what you see on YouTube
and Tik Tok just because there's so much
youth on it and youth has a specific
energy and a genre and things they talk
about and
energy uh and so that's you know that's
that question how do you all audit your
posts and contents what's your main kpi
for social do you use social media
management software or post natively on
platforms I'm a big believer in Native
like to me it's about reach it's about
awareness it's about understanding if
it's getting to people and it's
understanding the sentiment like the
comments like what people feel about it
you know I think it's a big factor
so um how can I learn to effectively
communicate like you practice I've been
practicing talking my whole life I
talked in class I talked after school I
talked to grown-ups I talked to kids you
know this is I'm 48 This is
40 five 43 years in the making when I
was 5 years old there's a great story my
mom always tells that I used to go out
with my great-grandfather Shia and we
take me out to the neighborhood in
Queens and I would just chat up old
dudes like all day just chatter box all
all day and chill and just jam with them
and like talk talk talk and so I love
people and so I just need to practice do
you think it has anything to do
with well caring about the other
person's opinion that's has a lot to do
with well yeah I think a lot of people
are shy or introverted because they're
scared yeah and so to your point I think
a lot of people are scared of other
people's opinions and I'm empathetic to
that and so you know you know this fear
is my great
enemy yeah so yes I'm willing to talk
because I'm not worried about the
Judgment but like my post this morning I
also think before you start working
on dealing with judgment one must stop
judging you know this about me and you
know this about you like this is real
talk this can help them if you're one to
judge you're going to be susceptible to
valuing the concept of
judgment because I don't judge I mean a
human of course I but but you know this
like you really know me now it's not
like everyone here like they know meish
you know me it's not my zone it's not
where I go I just don't jump to
conclusions I don't know what's going on
in people's lives and we are at the
height of judgment right now people do
it as a sport people go on their in
socials and not even on socials in life
people feel like appropriate to say [__]
to people now we've lost civility and
we're deploying judgment and so you're
deploying what I deem as a negative
energy thus making you susceptible to
the negative energy because you value
the Judgment because you're judging so
you think your judgment is valuable you
then are overvaluing other people's
Judgment of you and becomes a
self-filling circle of
[__] so stop [__] judging people and
find out how lovely that will be for
your own
life how about deploying like
nice and joy and like it's it's a
[__]
Boomerang you [__] get what you give
it's real [__] talk my advice Britain
run just said my advice to somebody
moving to New York for the first
time um eliminating fear people don't
listen to anyone because everyone's
going to tell you New York is scary
roommates are a good idea um but like
really being as social as you can take
take advantage of New York's greatest
power which is the people and again if
you're if you're not disappointed by
people hurting your feelings you can get
[Music]
there